[Music]
so today I'm going to talk about how I
got 1600 stars in GitHub in two months
of Open Source work
and but first I have a question for you
have you contribute to any open source
project really really giant
yeah your speaker typo
yeah cool so if you haven't I hope you
will after my talk so a little bit about
me I'm a creator of just preview just
preview a library that gives you a
visual debug experience when you're
testing a front-end app and also I'm a
core member of passofjet.off is a
website that helps you follow the growth
of the JavaScript ecosystem and yeah you
can connect with me with Twitter or
GitHub
uh
this is what I'm gonna cover first I
want to cover what is just preview and
why I pay with and I'm going to go
through what the shackle do I have to
overcome when I build when I build an
awareness project and what I what did I
received from joining the open source
community and lastly I will give you
some tips if you want to build your own
open source project
first what you just preview and why
build it
[Music]
um
uh I know that a lot of you guys you
react right and your front-end engineer
and if you ever write tasks in for
front-end app it's kind of yeah we don't
want to write as much right but when you
write this and you you experience some
book you might you might experience this
like that you have you have to see the
very long HTML in the terminal and yes
you just don't want to do it right so I
I think that what tip instead of looking
at the very long and boring HTML I can
visualize it in the browser so I try and
yeah I can do it this is my this is a
very quick demo of I have that here is a
react app and when you when you you
render it and you do some you do some
action like click on it click on it and
you just put the preview dot debug you
can see the actual UI in the test and
these two
this ah this Library I abuse that I view
this library to solve my problem itself
so turn out many many developers out
there they have the same problem and
yeah they they just say waste and they
say see that very useful and if you have
the same same scenario yes give it a try
and I think I want to do a little bit
more demo
two
here I have a react app and this a very
basic react app is have a cow and if you
click on this it's gonna increase one
and I have a test that I render an app
and click it 6 amp and I expect the cow
I have have to be sick but if I
add another life so it's not going to be
sick right the test will fail but if you
debug it in the test you have to see a
very
exactly HTML but I I try to visualize it
in the browser so you can see it easily
and many times you can debug the you can
spot the book faster
where my mouse
yeah
okay so I want to share some some
struggles I have to overcome when will
be reject preview
uh
the first one is difficult so I show
here is a style component I mean uh
almost if you write ever use serum you
know the the syntax right it's very easy
just import size from the Style style
module.c at and use it but when I I have
when I try to support serious module in
just preview I have to work it with much
more complex course but uh yeah I
learned a lot
the next one is to take a lot of time
when you build a an open source search
project and because when you view and
open you build a project because they
know there are no existing solution so
you are the one who try to resell it
sometime it takes a lot of time and
especially when you have full-time job
it when you return from work you do not
want to spend some time to do open
source right so as as I am now I'm a
full-time oversight I have always have
to plan and to to to spend on on open
source
and one more thing is ah
one almost that I thought is if it's an
open source project many people will
come to help you but it's not really and
sometimes working on open source that
you want to give up and okay the project
but whenever you reach that state just
remember why you want to start the open
source software project in the first
place
and one more thing is of one more
struggle is the the financially because
you just working for free when you work
at the company someone pay you to for
you to record but when you work on the
open source you just do some kind of of
Charity right so to solve this problem
um if you if you just do it for fun it's
fine right but if you spend many time on
this you have to fight something yeah
you can try GitHub sponsor you can try
some open Collective uh some kind of
Premium model like you have a free
version but if you if your user wants to
see want to have more support or have
some more feature you can check them
the next thing I want to share what I
received from the from doing open source
software the first one in knowledge I
learned a lot when I at my work I just I
am I'm a front-end engineer and I work
mostly in react I just know how to write
component write UI and write I mean how
to how to organize my component or how
to make it more efficiently but when I
doing open source work I have to know
what why why that worked and how that
work under the hood so I read a lot of
source code so my SKU reading code and
debuggling skill
might improve a lot and one one thing is
that it's like a rabbit hole when you
try to solve one problem but you'll find
some bug for example that I I I built
just preview but I have to read a lot of
project code and I click into the vid
card and so now I send them a couple of
pull requests so yeah it's just a rabbit
rabbit hole and you have to learn a lot
and you
yeah and and I know a lot about the how
about how modern how bundle work under
the hood and how they process that app
in modern application
the next thing is the opportunity
just for two months of Open Source work
I got my project got nominated for the
most exciting use of technology for an
erect open source award and
yeah it's it's very honor of me and also
I got many common company reach out for
job offer I think it's a good invest
and yeah I have chance to join a
conference and Tech event like your
escort
next I know a red developer
in in the past I never thought that I am
I'm gonna talk to many famous creator of
my favorite uh two I have some favorite
Library like MSW month service worker if
you ever use it a real cook form yeah I
never thought that I'm gonna be friend
with them but when I live into my open
source group yeah I finally get to know
them and many other
the developer and so now that's the year
they're very friendly and they will
support you
next I know a great developer in person
like uh in in July I attend another
conference in Singapore and I meet many
great people here here here Maya's mayor
Chavin from Microsoft Evangel creator of
UJS and Charlie how he a core member of
swell
next and I have chance to to meet you as
a head coach of Korea this year
and one one thing that I received from
doing open source software is that I
receive a lot of things
at a random moment in the day I some
some online guys told me that yeah uh
your your software just make me just
just make my life easier and thank you
for for that and that's the feeling that
I never get when I doing a nine to five
night to firework
and yeah I think that's the most
rewarding
and next so how to do that so so I I'm
gonna share some tips some of my
personal tips to build your own open
source project and I think there's a lot
more but I just picked some some of my
first a uh I think this is a more
important thing the most important
question is how to choose an open source
project to work on and
there are many answers so but it in my
opinion that
you have to contribute to the project
you use every day if you want to build
your own software open source software
you have just you have that software
that have to solve your own problem you
cannot find some random Project online
and hey I try to I try to contribute to
it but
it's very difficult to someone to
contribute to project that we do not
have any context at all so for example
that in the in the daily work I use Red
Hook formula so until now I can
contribute to to them and it's kind of
my my way to science and help the outer
and maintenance
second one is fire maintainer because
you know building an open source project
is very hard and shareful so it would be
easier for you to have someone to
discard Technical and motivate you to
continue to continue the project
the next one is that if you release an
open source project do not start it at
1.x because a new project is full of
proof of concept and experiment and
think on sing my head chain very quickly
and the sample the semantic version if
job software starts with one topic it
means your the next version has to be
backward compatible with the previous
version
uh otherwise you have to increase to the
to the major variant right like but uh
yeah if it's a new project I recommend
that you just use the major version zero
it's for initial development and
anything can change but the public API
should not be stable
so you can see that many famous projects
but they never it's not never it take a
very long time to reach 1.0 for example
surveyor swell is very close to 1.0 but
yeah not fair yet
and next next a police user or software
so when you you use your software as a
normal user you can add more feature or
you can adjust it to make it reusable
for example when I view just preview
um
oh I want I just want to put the HTML
into the browser that's all but when the
more I use I add many features to it
like the auto reload when in the in the
demo before when whenever I hit save the
test run finished and the browser reload
automatically and I have to when the
more I use I have to work on code how to
process that app or image otherwise it's
just the plain HTML in the browser
and you can ask for fish by
because when you build your software
your software can be subjective and
please ask your friend your college and
your network that if they use your
software and you can give you some
feedback and after a while maybe your if
your software
um if your software so uh so a kind of
real pinpoint people will come and watch
out for the UCL and discussions
discussion tab on on GitHub
let's learn from other so do not
reinvent the will so when we build a
open software project there are many
problems you have to solve that someone
already saw so uh learn from them read
their source code and maybe steal a
little bit but remember to create Great
lead them Picasso have a lies at this
still are good at this copy but great at
this deal so don't worry that you
sometimes you have to learn about as a
code and my project have to learn many
learn many things from wheat from create
rig app and many other projects
and another advice is you can write a
good documentation so uh
because it's very easy for you if you
build your own software but people
around the world they have very
difficult different UK and
you sometimes you do not you do not
imagine how the how the road use your
own software so just describe what
problem you trying to solve how the
installation installation and use it and
what can we ask they might encounter
when they use your software and it's
very uh if you prefer react the software
code servers and if you prefer view you
can you with with Express and this is my
documentation I try to make it very easy
to understand and how to use it uh how
to yeah you can run a demo on there you
can have to plug it into your your code
and next a
which will be a great software but
please say share it with the world I
think Twitter is the most amazing
platform you can share something with
the world and maybe you can write some
blog post and share it with other in the
tech event when I like I am I am doing
and yeah last but not least that
contribute to open source one today and
I hope you will you will have a lot of
fun and learn a ton when doing open sort
over project and thank you for attention
and this is a link to just preview and
if you're a front-end engineer maybe you
should chuckle developing test review
the child and give it a start finishing
it's free so thank you very much and the
slide available here yeah thank you very
much
[Applause]